[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans questions
politiques merci d'être fidèle au rendez
vous du dimanche de france inter du
journal le monde et de france info
notre invité aujourd'hui c'est un proche
parmi les proches du président de la
république
l'un des meilleurs connaisseurs des
stratégies politiques des cartes
électorales président du modem il nous
dira comment il imagine la campagne
présidentielle qui a déjà commencé quel
thème quelles alliances seront
déterminants pour l'emporter en 2022
et puis au delà bien au delà comment
nous projeter dans 5 ans 10 ans 20 ans
comment préparer la france aux grands
défis de demain et d'après demain alors
que tous nos repères tous nos repères
sont bousculés depuis maintenant un an
questions politiques de ce 14 mars est
en direct avec le haut commissaire au
plan président du modem et maire de pau
françois bayrou vos questions vos
réactions vos commentaires sur l'appli
france inter où les réseaux avec le
hashtag question paul france inter
question politique
ali baddou bonjour françois bayrou
bonjour et bienvenue pour vous
interroger l'équipe de questions
politiques nathalie saint cricq de
france télévisions bonjour nathalie
genre à livange ou françois bayrou
bonjour à tous françoise fressoz du
journal le monde bonjour françoise
bonjour à libon jours françois bayrou
bonjour à tous karine becquart de france
inter bonjour karine salut tout le monde
et salue françois bayrou évidemment
évidemment sujet sérieux françois bayrou
pour le coup à propos de la stratégie
sanitaire nous avons tous compris le
choix qu'a fait le président de la
république l'esprit en tout cas de sa
stratégie chaque jour non confiné est un
jour gagner c'est un pari qui a été fait
est ce que c'est un pari qui n'est pas
trop risqué
au bout du compte je pense c'est un pari
absolument juste
je ne crois pas qu on puisse enfermer un
pays durablement
je crois pas qu on puisse enfermer des
familles durablement je crois pas qu on
puisse enfermer des jeunes durablement
si c'est une courte période avec la
certitude ou en tout cas la probabilité
que on va stopper un moment
particulièrement virulent de l'épidémie
je comprends mais vous voyez bien que
les confinements successives que nous
avons choisi à mon sens ils ne sont pas
compréhensibles s'il ne débouche pas sur
autre chose et je crois que le président
de la république a eu raison de faire y
compris contre la plupart des experts et
des conseillers justement ce choix là et
je pense que on doit aujourd'hui
réfléchir à de nouvelles décisions une
nouvelle manière de prendre lesquels
mais quelle une étude vient de sortir
cette semaine
absolument éclairante et indiscutable
parce qu'elles portent sur des dizaines
de milliers de cas et elle dit quelque
chose d'extrêmement simple qu'à mon sens
il faut auquel à mon sens il faut que
nous réfléchissions que dit cette étude
elle dit les contaminations ont lieu
pour 80
15% dans un lieu clos pour les deux
tiers au moins de ces contaminations
dans un lieu clos fermé si les fenêtres
sont ouvertes
tout change et à l'extérieur il ya à
peine 5 % des contaminations et s'il ya
les distances et un masque s'il le faut
un masque si y'a pas les distances à ce
moment là il ya plus de contaminations
et vous voyez que pour tous ceux qui y
vivent ces situations et tous ceux qui
nous écoutent
il ya là quelque chose de 2,2
radicalement différente ce qu'on fait si
on pouvait rendre à chacun d'entre nous
le plein air la nature le jardin le
l'espace ouvert le les bords de seine le
ou des rivières qui passent dans chacune
de nos de nos villes ou du gave de pau
si par exemple il fallait chercher
c'était dans ce cours d'eau est donc
très beau vous savez ça donc
et donc si si on rend le play si on
rendait le plein air à tous ceux qui
sont angoissés de se trouver confirmé un
confiné fermés dans un appartement ne
pouvons pas sortir ça changerait si
beaucoup de jeunes rats héros une
question malgré tout puisque vous citez
cette étude effectivement une autre
étude menée par victoria colis zaki et
épidémiologiste et qui intervient très
régulièrement elle est chercheuse à
l'inserm au cours des conférences de
presse que tient le premier ministre
chaque semaine c'est elle qui présente
ses modèles que nous avons pris
l'habitude de voir tous les jeudis ou
quasiment à la question qui est posée à
vitoria kalisa on lui dit est ce qu'il
est possible de freiner l'épidémie sans
confiné sa réponse elle tient en quatre
mots c'est très peu probable
bon le les experts sont là pour apporter
leurs certitudes et c'est très bien
qu'on en tienne compte
moi je vous dis toute la question à
propos du président de la république
j'avais évité un confinement pardon
juste injuste de la cité éviter un
confinement présente des avantages
sociétaux et économiques mais cela
induit beaucoup d'infections
d'hospitalisation de kovy de long sans
parler des décès c'est ça le pari oui
dieu d'emmanuel macro son pari c'est que
on rende cette situation de lutte contre
le virus acceptable socialement
acceptable familialement acceptable pour
éviter de se trouver avec un grand
nombre de nos compatriotes qu'ils soient
enfermés dans une solitude qui elle est
invivable et qui portent atteinte à des
choses vraiment très très importante de
de l'âge de la rencontre de et je
voudrais ajouter une deuxième chose vous
aviez tout à leur demander quoi faire
donc je je sui fra vrai de madame je
suis frappé de voir que le plein air
n'est pas un lieu de contamination il ya
une deuxième chose mais les nerfs en
hiver ces pardons le plein air en hiver
c'est un peu compliqué maintenant qu'on
vient de convier de sortir chacun
d'entre nous a vu des beaux jours et
même sortir sous la pluie c'est pas
c'est pas un sujet il ya un deuxième
chose je trouve que l'éducation de la
population n'est pas faites comme elles
devraient être faites
alors qu'est-ce que je ne triche que par
exemple c'est très difficile de pour les
gens de se représenter quels sont les
vrais distance quand on doit mettre le
masque et qu'on doit pas y échapper
et je trouve qu'on aurait une campagne
d'éducation populaire sur le thème par
vaux par votre entremise l'entremise des
radios des télévisions des réseaux
sociaux
simplement pour être assurés que faut
ouvrir les fenêtres
chaque fois qu'on peut que un masque sas
mais dès l'instant qu'il n'ya pas les
distances y compris dans le cercle
familial
si on n'est pas assuré de l'état
sanitaire de ceux qui le composent
il ya un travail d'éducation populaire
très important qui pour l'instant je
trouve n'a pas été fait je trouve que
les français ceux qui nous entourent
sont pas très au clair sur la manière
dont le virus se transmet on a entendu
des choses dans tous les sens oui même
de la part de ministres
oui par exemple aujourd'hui le la
transmission par la main et est moins
mis en cause que la transmission par les
aérosols comme on dit je trouve que ce
travail d'éducation par des par une
communication percutante efficace et
simple serait elle aussi une manière de
lutter contre le virus et la manière la
plus important c'est la vaccination
évidemment karine bekaert puis de
l'analyse agricole mais françois bayrou
vous me donnez le sentiment je peux me
tromper que vous esquivez en fait notre
question notre question c'est de dire la
stratégie de macron la très bien
comprise elle a sans doute été juste il
ya encore quelques semaines quand on
voit la situation dans les hôpitaux dans
certaines régions je pense à
d'ile-de-france évidemment je pense
aussi aux trans je pense à la grande au
grand sud la région anciennement en paca
est ce qu'on n'a pas attendu trop
longtemps est ce que du coup le coût
politique pour emmanuel macron va pas
finir par être très cher oui je jeunesse
qui veut rien c'est tout à fait possible
que ya un sentiment que il aurait fallu
tout fermé moi j'ai dis seulement que je
comprenais le choix du président de la
république de ne pas tous fermés ya des
millions et des millions de français qui
le comprennent et qu'ils voient avec
angoisse
l'idée qu' on pourrait procéder à un ré
enfermement généralisée 1re confinement
généralisée est ce que je défends comme
idée c'est que peut-être il ya d'autres
moyens d'arriver à la sécurité sanitaire
que celui du confinement généralisée
pour des raisons qui tiennent pas
seulement à l'économie
ça compte mais qui tiennent à autre
chose qui tienne au caractère
insupportable de la solitude
enfermés pour un grand nombre de ceux
qui la vivent parce que bon quand vous
avez une famille ça va quand vous êtes
dans l'âge où on peut rencontrer des
gens ça va mais lorsque vous êtes dans
d'autres situations
je vois les étudiants qui parfois sont
sont tout seul moment d'entrer à la fac
n'ont pas d'amis et sont dans une
situation de 2,2 profond de gênes où de
profondes isolement et de profonde
tristesse
moi je pense et je pense aux personnes
plus âgées
il ya beaucoup de situations
personnelles et familiales dans
lesquelles la solitude est très
difficile à supporter d'autres solutions
de l'égalité 0 celle du pouvoir en
l'occurrence eric piolle le maire
écologiste sur notre antenne
concurrentes et hamid rtl il déclare
qu'il ne comprend plus rien à ce que
fait le président il annonce les
décisions seul dit eric piolle il n'ya
plus de démocratie sanitaire
vous êtes à la tête d'un mouvement qui
s'appelle le mouvement démocratique est
ce qu il a raison
plus de démocratie sanitaire bon le faut
bien que quelqu'un prenne des décisions
des débats à l'assemblée nationale il y
en a à chaque semaine
est ce que quelqu'un qui doit prendre
les décisions à raison de s'entourer des
conseils les plus les plus sérieux oui
il a raison
est-ce qu'on peut partager mieux sans
doute mais ça n'est pas le sujet
principal de ceux qui nous écoutent le
sujet principal de ceux qui nous
écoutent c est ce qu on referme
ou est-ce qu'on a une autre voie
l'étaler par exemple se voir confiné à
partir de lundi absolument l'italie à
partir de demain il ya une semaine
si on réfléchit aux lieux où la
contamination se passe et aux modes de
transmission du virus
alors je suis sûr qu'il y a une voix
différente de celle de
dur confinement généralisée va aller
serait finalement françois bayrou tout
le pari des manuels macron reposer sur
la vaccination massive
c'était des gens chaque jour gagné
c'était un jour on devait venir en
vaccinant vaccinant pour éviter leur
confinement est ce qu'aujourd'hui
confronté à l'absence de doses et non
pas la faiblesse de la logistique parce
que la logistique a l'air de rouler ben
justement c'est ça qui va nous ou leur
giroud l'obligé à retrouver on voit
parfaitement dormir on voit parfaitement
dans les courbes
aujourd'hui que la vaccination ça marche
oui enfin les plus de 80 ans qui sont
maintenant c'est pas un grand nombre
être vaccinés on voit que ça marche on
voit que les hospitalisations baisse on
voit que les réanimations baisse donc ça
marche
est ce que met le mois dernier a pas
terrible pardon le mois à venir
oui c'est olivier ferrand qu'il dit et
c'est une course ce n'est pas olivier
ferrand c'est la planète entière qui
voit les difficultés elles et les très
graves défis que cette épidémie propose
en tout cas au monde occidental parce
que il ya d'autres régions du monde qui
sont plus préservées mais je pense que
nous mais regardez par exemple vous êtes
un européen convaincu les difficultés
qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui dans l'espace
européen et le commissaire européen
thierry breton ce matin était très en
colère contre le groupe pharmaceutique
astrazeneca groupe qui annonçait hier
une réduction des livraisons de vaccins
contre le coronavirus pour la deuxième
fois depuis le début du mois de janvier
annonce inacceptable dit thierry breton
comment l'expliquez vous c'est lui qui
sait mieux que moi je pense que
lorsque vous avez l'offre et la demande
et que la demande augmente de manière
considérable et que l'offre ne suit pas
vous avez des mécanismes hélas de marché
ça se produit pas aux états unis
pourquoi ça se produit pas en grande
bretagne grande bretagne c'est pas un
plaidoyer pour l'europe ça non mais mais
est ce que l'union européenne à son
corps défendant n'a pas misé sur le bon
vaccin finalement extradé ce n'était pas
le bon guily held on va on va s'accorder
est ce qu'il y a eu des erreurs
peut-être est-ce qu'on peut les corriger
oui d'ici très très peu de semaines on
devrait avoir une offre de vaccins
immense on a dans dans la ville dans
dont j'ai la responsabilité à pau on va
mettre en place à partir du mois de mai
une unité de production et de est de
mise en place de vaccin qui va faire un
million de bouteilles par mois et chaque
bouteille contient 20 doses ça fait 20
millions tout casser les prévisions
alors ça n'est pas que pour la france
naturellement mais il ya plusieurs
unités comme ça en france
et ça n'est qu'un vaccin ces deux
vaccins allemande qui s'appelle curé
vague croix à partir du mois de mai
d'autres vaccins ont été acceptés hier
ça va venir
qu est ce qu on a vécu tous ensemble on
a vécu quelque chose d'assez simple
c'est que il ya un mois ou un mois et
demi le les projecteurs de l'opinion
publique que vous que vous relayez était
contre la vaccination
1 quand j'ai quand je me suis mis en
avant décembre mais bourdon janvier même
quand je me suis battu pour la
vaccination j'ai même évoqué l'idée d'un
certificat de vaccination d'un passeport
vaccinale comme on dit mais ça a été des
levées de boucliers incroyable tout le
monde était contre la vaccination puis
tout d'un coup on se trouve dans une
situation où tout le monde ouvre une
polémique parce qu'il n'ya pas assez de
vaccins probablement est-ce que des
choses ont été
toujours bien fait je n'en suis pas sûr
est ce qu'il y avait d'autres chemins je
ne sais pas mais je sais une chose avec
certitude c'est que cette épidémie la
qui était une épidémie inédite - il ya
des réponses et des réponses qui
viennent et qui viennent dans les
semaines qui viennent et probablement
signer personnellement je ne suis pas
encore je le serai quand ma classe d'âge
sera atteinte je n'ai pas voulu de passe
droit ça viendra ça va ça va venir
alors il s'intéresse à jour une question
qui est peut-être un peu plus humaine
mal je ne sais pas est ce que vous
considérez vous qui connaissez bien
emmanuel macron qu'il a changé après
cette année c est cette épreuve du
pouvoir ce confinement et en quoi at il
changé
il a changé depuis quatre ans parce que
il l'a découvert c'est un homme très
jeune qui a été élu président de la
république de manière complètement
inattendue au terme d'un mouvement de
révolution qui a été proposé aux
français que les français ont adopté et
puis il a découvert que la réalité la
perception qu'on pouvait avoir d'un
dirigeant dans l'opinion publique dans
les médias qui pouvait être extrêmement
déformé extrêmement éloignée de ce que
lui étaient ou avaient le sentiment
d'être il a découvert que c'était très
dur
il joue là il joue là les savoirs des
gens là aussi si vous voyez sont son
visage oui je trouve que son visage a
changé
pour ma part en mieux je trouve que des
rides de soucis d'inquiétude de ça
traduit mieux que la légèreté du très
jeune âge ce qu'est cette fonction les
français savent et absolue pardon les
français se trompent ou se sont trompés
à son propos je pense que
l'homme qu'il est n'est pas perçu par la
majorité des français est donc le
problème est l'homme qu'il est ou de ce
que les français peuvent avoir en tête
bon c'est pas moi qui veux dire le
contrat j'ai commencé ma mes relations
avec lui de manière polémique de manière
un peu un peu dur est donc simplement le
les reproches qui lui sont faits la
perception qu'ils aient fait que
quelqu'un qui ne considère pas les gens
c'est de ce que je vois tous les jours
c'est absolument faux et de ce que je
vois quand il est en situation avec des
gens de terrain avec les femmes et les
hommes et les familles et les élus
locaux en situation difficile au
contraire son son regard est un regard
qui prend les gens en compte
deuxièmement on a dit c'est l'homme des
puissants je n'ai pour ma part jamais vu
un président de la république qui soit
aussi indépendant des puissants que lui
françois mitterrand peut-être si je dors
remonter le temps cette espèce de il
n'est manipuler obtenu par personne
alors que beaucoup de gens ont cru
qu'ils étaient plutôt l'homme des
puissants des puissances 3e 3e
perception puis on s'arrêtera là
l'idée de l'hégémonie l'idée de
l'hégémonie elle est dans nos
institutions
si on change pas les institutions on
aura perpétuellement cette accusation la
ce que voulait dire c'est que jupiter
est inscrit dans les textes de la vème
république
alors l'éthique alors on va faire une
minute de sciences politiques
ça n'est pas inscrit dans les textes on
peut avoir une autre perception par
exemple en cohabitation on a eu une
autre perception des présidents de la
république
mais si vous avez un président de la
république élu au scrutin majoritaire et
si vous avez une chambre qui est
simplement la duplication du scrutin
alors vous êtes dans une situation où il
n'y a plus de dialogue nécessaire entre
exécutif et législatif le vous avez
qu'est ce que c'est la 5ème république
c'est un président choisi par les
français pour qu'il trace la ligne et
c'est une représentation nationale
une assemblée nationale qui est fait
pour représenter les différentes
sensibilités donc revenir au septennat
par exemple personnel parce que c'est
votre combat de fin de quinquennat c'est
la proportionnelle c'est le combat du
début
c'est le combat du début quand tu vas
devoir belle que c'était dans l'alliance
que nous avons conclu avec meinl que
j'aurai je pense que c'est présent la
république ou est ce que ce sont les
autres partis que vous n'arrivez pas à
convaincre là dessus pas du tout ce qui
bloque c'est que pour l'instant on n'a
pas trouvé la démarche démocratique
nécessaire pour que le choix des
français s'exprime et se fassent
entendre
je n'ai jamais cru qu'on pouvait y
arriver par la voie parlementaire parce
que vous avez une assemblée qui est élu
selon un certain une certaine
organisation
elle va pas spontanément elle aurait pu
le faire au début je vous rappelle que
j'ai proposé un référendum
j'étais garde des sceaux à l'époque j'ai
proposé fugacement j'ai proposé un
référendum
le jour du deuxième tour des élections
législatives pour que ça soit réglé
on m'a dit c'est trop tôt et maintenant
c'est trop tard et après pendant le
quinquennat
on m'a dit
les forces politiques ont dit c'est pas
le moment puis maintenant d'y être c'est
trop tard et vous voyez là le l'éternel
recommencement que nous connaissons
depuis un demi siècle sur ce sujet là
c'est à dire que en réalité sous des
prétextes divers à personne ne veut
jouer ce que vous en voyez encore vous
avez quand même le téléphone de manuel
macro je vais vous répondre dans ce nid
soyez et de ce que c'est un casus belli
pauvre je vais vous répondre dans une
seconde
premièrement ce à quoi nous sommes
confrontés c'est le conservatisme
éternel des forces politiques qui
veulent garder le pouvoir pour elle des
forces politiques majoritaires qui
croient qu'elles vont le rester
s'il regarde l histoire il verrait il
verrait une conclusion différente quand
ils vont le rester et donc surtout on ne
touche à rien pour moi pour mon
sentiment c'est une faute
est-ce que je suis résigné est ce que
j'y crois encore plus que jamais alors
je lis très rien je lis très bien ce que
vous écrivez ou ce que vous dites c'est
à dire que le tous les bruits qui
viennent des couloirs de pouvoir quels
que soient les couloirs de pouvoir c'est
cause toujours tu m'intéresses
mais ce que c'est ça qui vous dit
emmanuel macron vous voulez parler nous
pas parfait mais ça dépend de lui et
françois bayrou il vous a fait sept
projets sera assez laid votre à lire je
suis affecté tiendra-t-il safran mais je
suis affecté d'une maladie que je dois
vous avouer à l'entraînement qui est
très très pénalisante c'est que je suis
frappée d'amnésie sur toutes mes
conversations avec le président de la
république c'est comme ça c'est la
fraude et ses rythmes réguliers même
plus de l'alliance que vous avez serré
s'insulter ce n'était pas une mauvaise
chose
c'est peut-être un projet politique il
ya une conversation et est associé vous
êtes en situation finalement de croire
aux promesses qu'on vous fait eh bien je
je suis précisément des très rares
hommes politiques qui croient que les
promesses n'engagent qu'elle est votre
dommage pour y croire si le dit assez
simple premièrement tous ceux qui
regardent le fonctionnement de notre
démocratie constate qu'il ya quelque
chose qui ne va pas tout ce qu'ils
regardent concise constate qu' un
déséquilibre qu'on a le sentiment que le
pouvoir est toujours enfermé qu'il prend
ses décisions tout seul on en a eu
l'écho tout à l'heure
quel que soit le président de la
république quelles que soient les
circonstances historiques et on a une
deuxième certitude c'est que les
français de plus en plus s'éloigne des
élections de la vie démocratique
considère que tout ça c'est n'importe
quoi pourquoi ils sont pas représentés
on a un parlement en parlement c'est
fait pour représenter les citoyens dans
lesquelles plus de 50 % des citoyens ne
sont pas représentés ça nous on est des
parce qu'elle ne soit pas ça c'est un
diagnostic non notation présentation et
que c'est le premier parti a dit tout
parce que leur vote à du tout parce que
leur vote à l'assemblée nationale pas
dans les autres élections n'est pas
prise en cause par exemple le moi je
vois les les prises de position des uns
et des autres le président du sénat
gérard larcher a pris position avec
virulence contre la loi électorale juste
qu'est la proportionnelle ça fait rire
parce que gérard larcher il est lui élu
comme sénateur à la proportionnelle
depuis toujours les trois quarts des
sénateurs sont élus à la proportionnelle
à voir et faire un verre que vous voulez
emprunter
concrètement vous l'organiser comment
bon je pense que si l'on fait le constat
qu'il y à une question qui empoisonne le
débat public depuis longtemps les gilet
jaune en ont beaucoup parlé dans leur
cahier de doléances ils ont dit très
souvent qui n'étaient pas représentés
si on fait ce constat alors on se tourne
vers notre histoire et nos institutions
et on dit aux français
il va falloir que vous tranchez voulait
france à l'automne je pense ça serait
pas mal de le faire en même temps que
les régionales a déjà déjà des joints
dès juin si elles ont lieu en juin mais
ce qu'on observe et vous avez des
discussions je vous ai dit je vous ai
dit quel était mon problème de santé
mais vous sectionné ou pas sur une
possibilité que ça puisse aboutir on
verra moi je veux oui la possibilité
institutionnelle elle est très simple et
ça ajoute quelque chose à nos
institutions qui pour l'instant n'existe
pas et qui est un manque
il faut qu'il y ait un instrument qui
permettent aux français de se prononcer
sans que soit en question la tête du
président de la république mais est ce
que justement ça peut pas être le cas
est-ce que ça ça peut se faire le
référendum comme ça même si c'est en
juin
oui ça peut se faire ça peut se perdre
les penny sa belle-mère
je n'ai jamais recommandé que le
président de la république dise voilà ce
que moi je veux des enfants qui naissent
malaxeur françois bayrou
non non je vous rappelle qu ont signé
une lettre la même lettre au président
de la république de jean-luc mélenchon à
marine le pen en passant jean christophe
magail à terre par les écologistes
en passant par toutes les forces du
centre et des personnalités éminentes du
ps et de l'ump de l erdre
personnalité éminente par exemple
rebsamen vallini on dit mais ça a
toujours été notre demande nous le parti
socialiste c'est le mode de scrutin que
demandait léon blum et café appliquée
françois mitterrand et donc ils ont dit
franchement c'est pas raisonnable que
nous ne soyons pas là et gérard longuet
à l air a fait un texte tout à fait
danser tout à fait important il dit
c'est le seul moyen de changer les
rapports entre l'exécutif et le
législatif mais malgré tout françois
bayrou doute toutes ses sensibilités là
si elles peuvent proposer un texte
sérieux par exemple le texte a déjà été
appliquée en 1986 alors y'a rien de plus
simple que de demander aux français ce
qu'il en est et le président de la
république pardon et la proportionnelle
intégrale ça c'est pas intégral c'est le
proportionnel départemental avec un
seuil à 5%
c'est le scrutin que françois mitterrand
avait vous connaissez quand même leurs
proches sous le commentaire qu'on fait
quand on entend parler de cette
question-là de courant par françois
bayrou
on est en pleine crise sanitaire crise
économique crise sociale nous traversons
une période de catastrophe philly à la
crise écologique qui se rajoute à ça et
on nous parle de proportionnelle et bien
et les politiques sont mobilisés sur la
question et il se déchire sur il vient
vous relève justement de l'organisation
est nécessaire que vous connaissez
sceptre très significative histoire
chinoise proverbe chinois qui dit quand
le doigt montre la lune l'imbécile
regarde le doigt
c'est un débat en effet qui paraît loin
des gens mais la vérité c'est que on est
là au coeur du coeur des raisons qui
font que économiquement ça ne va pas que
du point de vue sanitaire ça ne va pas
c'est ce que vous disiez que du point de
vue de l'opinion publique
que ça ne va pas que dieu qu'on a le
sentiment que les pouvoirs sont toujours
isolées seuls dans leur tour d'ivoire
qu'ils imposent en matière de liberté ou
en matière de écologie qu'ils imposent
des décisions qui ne ressemble pas à ce
que les citoyens souhaitent tant que
vous ne rendrai pas au au peuple
français sans vouloir employer des des
superlatifs
tant que vous ne leur rendrai pas une
représentation honnête qui fasse que
chacun des grands courants du pays
trouvent à être un parti prenante du
débat que l'on mène et puissent
contrôler le gouvernement
la proportionnelle en tout cas la
représentation juste c'est ça qu'il faut
dire oui passer l'émission l'a vu la
représentation juste ça parce que c'est
une question c'est qui concerne la
souveraineté ça c'est la question du
mans les day by institutionnels - ça une
conséquence vous vous trompez si vous
pensez que si vous pensez que les
institutions ça ne compte pas je pense
que c'est essentiel le ce a une
conséquence une loi électorale juste
c'est que quand vous êtes au pouvoir
vous êtes obligé de tenir compte des
autres
mais malgré tout françois bayrou si on
observe vos cote de popularité elle
diminue en ce moment elle perdre
quelques points
est-ce que malgré tout si dans le
dernière ifop qui a été publiées dans
paris-match par exemple vous perdez 5
points est ce que vous le lier à votre
combat depuis plusieurs semaines sur la
proportionnelle et est ce que vous avez
vraiment le sentiment que ça fait partie
des attentes en ce moment d'événements
lorsque vous êtes un responsable public
vous êtes obligé de discerner des
problèmes même quand l'opinion publique
ne les ressent pas je vous rappelle que
je me suis battue sur la dette et les
salades être que ça n'était pas
populaire
dieu sait qu'on en a fait des reproches
et parfois même des moqueries mais
c'était un vrai sujet et j'ai assez
assez souvent je me suis battu tout seul
contre la privatisation des autoroutes
tout seul
dieu sait qu'à l'époque ce n'était pas
un sujet et aucune force politique
n'était à ce combat à ce rendez vous il
arrive qu'on soit minoritaire et c'est
une comment je peux dire ça à 7
c'est un honneur d'être minoritaire
quand on est du côté de ceux qu'on croit
juste les combats politiques ça n'est
pas des combats démagogique
la démocratie c'est pas la démagogie
ça n'est pas d'aller toujours dans le
sens de l'opinion bien sûr que ces
problèmes institutionnels apparaissent
comme des problèmes un peu lointain la
vérité c'est qu'ils sont au coeur du
rapport entre le pouvoir et les citoyens
et de la délégation des citoyens alors
pour le pouvoir français nous expliquer
en quoi ce qu'il y avait une
proportionnelle ça changerait aussi la
perspective de la prochaine
présidentielle est ce que ça changerait
la perspective de la campagne est ce
qu'il y aurait une idée de coalition qui
pourrait être créé est-ce que du coup ça
pourrait aussi revigoré le front
républicain
alors on mélange tout je veux pas lysing
et lange et où première question est ce
que ça peut changer la prochaine
présidentielle
réponse il faut que ça change la
prochaine présidentielle dans quel sens
parce que il n'est pas possible de
proposer aux français que le quinquennat
qui vient soit exactement le même avec
ses difficultés et ses impuissances que
le quinquennat précédent
il faut changer le rapport au pouvoir et
c'est j'en suis sûr une des questions
que les français se posent à propos de
la manière d'exercer sa liste du foie
zealand les forces et les forces
politiques volontaires l'info donnée à
tous les français le droit la légitimité
de se faire entendre dans le débat c'est
pas compliqué sont des citoyens comme
nous prenez un exemple vous êtes
électeur à neuilly vous êtes de gauche
votre voix ne sert jamais à rien parce
que par définition ou bien vous êtes
électeur du centre ou de droite à saint
denis
votre voix ne sert jamais à rien parce
que c'est pas la majorité
c'est n'importe quoi alors est-ce qu'on
doit le corriger il ya des gens qui
disent c'est pas le moment c'est trop
tôt c'est trop tard
c'est pas le moment moi je vous dis si
on est responsable si on veut pas voir
se multiplier les les sécessions haut d
une société
un sociologue avait écrit un livre sur
ce sujet il ya pas longtemps une société
en sécession en révolte perpétuel sans
que jamais aucun message ne puisse pas
c'est vraiment il parlait surtout de
l'association des élites par le cou pour
le coup oui de la sécession du pays par
rapport aux élites
c'est ça le sujet est donc oui il faut
changer ça deuxièmement oui ce n'est pas
indifférent que un très grand nombre de
mouvements politiques extrêmement
différents les uns des autres portent le
même projet parce que ça veut dire qu'on
peut trouver d'autres rapports que le
rapport de domination
une majorité qui écrase et ignore les
minorités c'est absurde
je pense que ça peut changer les choses
ça veut dire que vous ferez alliance et
qu'en l'occurrence l'alliance continuera
entre le modem et la république en
marche dans la perspective de la
présidentielle ce qu'il faut comprendre
entre autres il faut d'abord attendre de
savoir si le président de la république
prend la décision de se représenter ou
le souhaitez vous je pense que le
travail n'est pas achevé et qu'il
convient à tout prix de donner à
l'espoir que ce l'élection d' emmanuel
macron a représenté une perspective de
réalisation juste pour comprendre et
compléter la question de françoise on a
l'impression que le front républicain
c'est à dire ce qui est clair existé
pendant des années et des années c'est
une espèce de barrage les élus de
rassemblement national mais c'est
quelque chose qui est en train de sauter
ça saute parce qu'on a l'impression
qu'il ya des gens de gauche déçus par
emmanuel macron qu'ils battent moi
j'irai à la pêche
si à mâcon le pen on a l'impression que
jean luc mélenchon dit à peu près la
même chose tout en étant faisant
quelques précisions est ce que vous êtes
inquiet par cette diffa ce dissolution
cette disparition de cette idée du
barrage au rassemblement national
françois je n'ai pas la même idée que la
plupart de ceux qui s'expriment sur ce
je suis là c'est pour ça que ces deux
inspectrices
moi je pense qu'une élection
présidentielle ne se gagne pas en se
résignant à faire échec à l'un ou à
l'autre ça compte pourtant très souvent
le cas mais ça ne se gagne pas comme ça
l'élection présidentielle ça se gagne
sur de l'espoir ça se gagne sur deûle
enthousiasme ça se gagne sur une
capacité de réunir les français ça se
gagne pas en en créant des épouvantails
parce que le temps des épouvantails est
finie c'est derrière nous les gens ont
vu que bon hein ce on faisait deux de
grands discours que généralement ce
n'était pas comme ça que les choses se
passaient et qu' ils ont désormais
besoin de croire à quelque chose alors
je suis minoritaire puisque tout le
monde dit que ce qu'il faut c'est le
front national pour les aux républicains
pour les autres je ne crois pas assez à
ces forteresses potemkine je pense qu'on
se rassure à bon compte si on va dans ce
sens là ce que je crois - c'est qu'il
faut donner de la vitalité de la volonté
de l'espoir de l'enthousiasmé du
rassemblement ça ça vaut la peine
mais si on va dans cette élection
uniquement 10 ans vous n'avez pas à vous
ne voterez pas pour l'autre c'est pas
possible vous allez tout ça marchera pas
comme ça voyez bien que les gens
s'échappe
donc je plein et on al'impression
pourtant que l'espoir et marine le pen
et le président de la république
installe ce duel et leur troupe
également dans l'espace public c'est une
petite musique qu'on ne peut pas ne pas
entendre si je fais le tour de la table
vous étiez tous des observateurs
politiques conscients sur les vingt
dernières années pour simplifier il se
trouve que passablement moi j'ai donné
les textes et donc et donc
c'est et attentif en tout cas et donc et
donc moi même je j'ai fait des tirades à
ces micro pour dire que c'était pas
possible ségo sarko qu'on installait des
duels que tout le monde était complice
il m'est arrivé de le dire de manière un
peu forte et entendue je dois dire mais
c'est très simple la question c'est où
sont les électeurs se trouve qu'il y a
pour l'instant dans les sondages qui
valent ce qu'ils valent
il ya des électeurs des millions de
personnes qui se sentent d'un candidat
ou d'un autre est ce que ça peut changer
oui ça peut changer mais je vous ai
répondu je ne crois pas moi qu'une
élection présidentielle se joue sur la
résignation à écarter quelqu'un de tout
crois pas ça je crois que l'élection
présidentielle ça se gagne sur du
positif ça se gagne sur de l'espoir et
ça se gagne sur la capacité à se faire
entendre des gens et si on joue le
contraire alors on se trompera le
président du modem et maire de pau
françois bayrou est l'invité de
questions politiques jusqu'à 13 heures
ali baddou questions politiques votre
portrait françois bayrou signé bien sûr
karine l'écart pendant plus de vingt ans
vous avez été persuadé françois bayrou
vous avez même presque tout misé sur
cette idée en particulier de réunir
toutes les bonnes volontés les bonnes
volontés de droite comme de gauche
c'était pour vous politiquement la seule
manière de tout changer de tout
réinventer
emmanuel macron l'a fait ou en tout cas
essayer ce n'est pas faute pour vous
d'avoir tenté de l'accompagner mais vous
en conviendrez françois bayrou difficile
de dire que cette affaire est
parfaitement fonctionné alors aurez vous
une autre idée pour l'année prochaine
pour l'élection présidentielle serez
vous toujours aussi écouter à l'elysée
avec une vraie capacité à influencer
il y a quatre ans précisément le futur
président n'avait pas hésité à venir
vous chercher parce qu'il avait besoin
du politique visible et expérimenté que
vous étiez mais désormais
qu'espérez-vous encore françois bayrou
lui apporter votre recul peut être votre
sens de la résilience ou bien votre
éternel optimisme malgré toutes ces
années où tout a souvent été assez
compliqué il ya eu un moment de ma vie
où j'ai su qu'il fallait
changer les choses en france et pas être
un acteur du jeu habituel et ça ça se
fait dedans
ça se fait un nom
dans le caractère d'un homme ou d'une
femme
ça se fait dans le caractère d'un homme
ou d'une femme mars 2010 est en fait à
bien vous observez il y a 2 françois
bayrou deux grandes époques
l'une où tout vous a été donné l'autre
où tout s'est mis à vous résister dans
les années 90 vous avez la quarantaine
tous et impeccablement déroulé vous êtes
nommé deux fois ministre ministre de
l'éducation nationale au plan local
vous êtes élu président des pyrénées
atlantiques votre département et vous
avez dirigé tous les partis centristes
c'est des sfd et bien sûr l'udf
bref on vous veut françois bayrou et
surtout on vous voit partout et puis
dans les années 90 la dynamique s'est
cassé vous n'avez plus qu'un seul but
l'élection suprême sauf contre elle et
vous ça n'a jamais marché
trois tentatives au total à la 4è vous
ralliez emmanuel macron et vous ne
gagnerez que par procuration avec très
simple je vais tout faire et d apporter
son expérience cette sensibilité c'est
d'ailleurs cette différence entre nous
qui est aussi une complémentarité
mais après quatre années passées à ses
côtés qu avez-vous su imposer françois
bayrou certes quelques postes et place
depuis longtemps vous savez négocier et
peser mais sur le fond qu'avez vous
sincèrement insuffler vous avait espéré
une autre manière de parler et
d'incarner la politique avec de
nouvelles pratiques un peu plus
démocratique reconnaissait qu à un an de
la fin du pacte que vous avez scellé
avec l'actuel président assez peu de
conditions ont été pour l'instant
rigoureusement respecté réaction
françois bayrou je vous ai écouté
attentivement je vous écoute toujours
attentivement
il ya un parti pris dans pas un parti
pris il ya un angle dont votre analyse
et cet angle c'est l'angle que beaucoup
de gens adoptent qui est l'angle
monarchiste monarchique le papier dit
est ce que vous avez eu de l' influence
est ce que vous aurez de l' influence
auprès du décideur suprême
il se trouve que je ne crois pas à cette
vision
pour moi la politique est un combat
c'est un engagement et on n'est pas en
situation de demander quelque chose on
est en situation de faire entendre ce
que ce qu'un pays dit ce qu une
situation historique exige vous avez
compris ça je suis pas un courtisan
jamais été jamais été prisonnier de
cette vision des choses
j'ai avec emmanuel macron la personne
une relation je crois de confiance assez
si j'osais je dirais assez profonde mais
je ne suis pas à essayer de susciter
quelque chose de sa part quand je vois
une situation grave pour le pays je le
dis même si ça fait pas plaisir aux
cercles de pouvoir exemple j'ai dit
qu'il allait faire falloir un plan
marshall pour essayer de reconstruire
l'appareil productif français qui s'est
affaibli au travers des années nous
sommes incapables y compris de faire
face à une partie majoritaire de la
demande intérieure du pays
on est le pays en europe qui a le
déficit du commercial le plus effrayant
on a 70 milliards
115 où certains disent
80 de déficit du commerce extérieur
tandis que l'allemagne à 200 milliards
d'excédents et que même l'italie est en
excédent
on est un pays dans lequel on ne sait
plus produire c'est un sujet qui est un
sujet majeur même si on vous dit c'est
pas urgent on ne sait pas le moment où
le tel plan suffit ça n'est pas vrai et
donc les combats que je mène ce sont des
combats qui ne sont pas des combats
comment dire l influence ce sont des
combats où on fait entendre le pays et
c'est ça le rôle d'un responsable
policier alors justement c'est que je ne
me je ne me sens pas dans votre angle
pour une fois on a des questions à vous
poser et qui touche justement aux
convictions et parfois même aux
convictions les plus intimes dans
l'actualité on voulait aussi vous
interroger sur l'euthanasie ou en tout
cas l'assistance à la mort dans la
dignité à cette possibilité là est-ce
qu'il faut l'élargir est ce que vous
comprenez qu'il y ait une proposition de
loi donnant le droit à une fin de vie
libre et choisit l'assemblée nationale
devrait examiner ce texte début avril
c'est pas si la réflexion a été
suffisamment conduite mais je vais vous
dire quelque chose qui est très intime
pour moi j'avais deux amis qui étaient
des enseignants que j'avais beaucoup
aimé même d'émettre en tout cas pour
l'un d'entre eux ils se sont suicidés
dans des conditions horribles ont voulu
mettre fin à leurs jours et c'était pour
l'un et pour l'autre des conditions
horribles
je pense que c'est un débat qu'il faut
il faut avoir en même temps vous savez
quelles sont mes convictions les plus
profondes je suis pour
je trouve que la vie est la chose la
plus sacrée qu'on puisse trouver bon et
vous avez soutenu la loi leonetti en
l'occurrence en disant qu'elle était
plutôt bien équilibré oui elle et
d'autres estiment qu'elle ne va pas
assez loin et qu'elle permet par va
avoir le débat va avoir le débat les
débats sur les sujets éthiques
ils doivent être conduits est menée et
si l'on peut les conduire et les menées
avec respect des opinions différentes
c'est aussi une manière de laïcité ça le
respecter le plus profond des opinions
des convictions que portent les nos
concitoyens alors je trouve que ça
mérite qu'on dire sur ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure en disant il faut mener
une campagne présidentielle qui soulève
l'espoir et l'enthousiasmé
quand on voit dans l'état dans lequel la
france sort du confinement ou essayent
d'en sortir
est-ce qu'il ya encore matière à mener
des campagnes optimiste et sur quel
sujet on peut le faire
françois bayrou nous sommes un pays qui
s'est sorti de deux guerres mondiales
dont la première a été la plus
épouvantable c'est nier qu'on pouvait
imaginer pour un peuple un million et
demi de jeunes garçons tués c'est une
saignée dont on n'est pas remis encore
mais on a fait faillite assurée annuel
macron la campagne qui était extrêmement
optimiste qui disait on va faire le pari
européen on va avoir de la croissance on
va faire de l'égalité des chances
là c'est plus c'est plus le sujet du
tout don et bien forum métiers de
l'outil le satde redevienne mais la
question la question c'est l'élan vital
du pays la question fondamentale c'est
pourquoi je crois que quand il ya une
forme de mystique quand vous employer
cette expression non dans l'élan vital
du pays qu'est ce que ça peut
les étalons vous est agrégé de
philosophie me semble-t-il
oui mais encore une fois ça c'est
l'ensemble d'un sas et bergson et ça
s'applique à l'ensemble
tant pis on va pas avoir des débats de
ceux de ce genre là moi je crois mais
vous le sentez les non-dits gel encore
je vais prendre un exemple
c'est un problème majeur sur lequel je
vais essayer de produire une note avec
le plan c'est un problème majeur que la
démographie de la france s'effondre
on a besoin d'avoir des naissances qui
permettront de porter ce qu'est notre
avenir notre recherche
nos découvertes et le contrat social qui
a entre nous notre démographie
s'effondre c'est un grand sujet c'est de
l'élan vital alors à propos des lans
vital l'année soit vraiment bien ça
la liaison est ce que vous vous
considérez que jean castex est rentré
dans un papier dans le monde je croyais
qu'ils rentraient dans la peau du
véritable premier ministre et ce qu'il
joue le rôle d'un bon paratonnerre et
protège suffisamment emmanuel macron et
entraîne suffisamment le pays doit
jamais pensé que la fonction d'après le
ministre était d'être paratonnerre mais
je pense que la fonction d'un premier
ministre est d'être un complément juste
positif et adapté au président de la
république il est celui qui met en
oeuvre qui fait entrer dans la réalité
il se cogne le réel et il fait face à ce
réel et je trouve regretté edouard
philippe
et je trouve que jean castex le fait
bien vous regrettez doit philippe j'ai
jamais à nantes lui a nommé un président
dela d'un premier ministre et donc je
n'ai pas calé dans ce genre de
considérations allard jean castex le
premier ministre qui se cogne le réel
dans ce réel en ce moment il ya
notamment les violences urbaines qui à
nouveau j'ai envie de dire se
multiplient en banlieue parisienne en
particulier dans l'essonne en banlieue
lyonnaise également mais pas seulement
on parle aussi de l'oise je crois
on découvre l'ampleur du phénomène des
rixes et des règlements de comptes entre
bandes
vous êtes dans la vie politique depuis
trente cinq ans françois bayrou c'est
ces problèmes là reviennent cycliquement
ce reviennent régulièrement
pourquoi n'arrive pas trop de solution
et qu'elle serait tel françois bayrou
parce que on ne sait pas bien analyser
ce que doit être une sanction et on ne
sait pas bien analyser ce que doit être
une éducation donc la sanction quand ces
jeunes font des bêtises faut attendre
deux ans parfois qui est une décision et
souvent elle n'est pas appliquée par
exemple j'ai appris récemment que des
jeunes condamnés à des travaux d'intérêt
général ce qui pour moi est une raison
mais il faut qu'il soit effectué les
travaux d'intérêt général et j'ai appris
que ils pouvaient ne pas être effectués
ou que on pouvait les en dispensait pour
les premiers ou que ça n'est pas normal
je pense que la rapidité de la sanction
et l'effectivité de la sanction sont
quelque chose qui devrait être un devoir
pour nous tous nous avons dans notre
ville pris près de 150 offert près de
150 travaux d'intérêt général parce que
c'est mieux d'être au boulot que d'être
en prison mais au boulot à condition que
ça respecte parce que la prison est très
souvent un lieu de contagion des
pratiques les plus ou des attitudes les
plus détestables et deuxièmement oui je
pense qu'il ya un très gros travail
d'éducation à faire dans les collèges et
dans les lycées et travail d'éducation
populaire dans la rue avec pour que on
habitue en pur comme n'accepte plus de
se résigner
quand vous avez 15 gosse 15 coste 15
jeunes gens dans une cité qui sème le
bazar qui participe à tous les trafics
et qui défie la police ça ne devrait pas
pouvoir être acceptée sans rien dire ça
ne doit pas voilà c'est un impératif
l'émission se termine françois bayrou
question traditionnelle mais
qui est imposé par l'agenda des
commémorations ça fait sourire nathalie
saint cricq parce que ça tourne à une
obsession personnelle mais n'y voyez pas
une obsession nathalie faut-il
commémorer le bicentenaire de la mort de
napoléon 1er
est-ce qu'il faut commémorer napoléon
oui c'est 1 2 c'est une des grandes
figures de la france vous savez on est
perpétuellement soumis à une dérive qui
est que on veut juger les figures de
l'histoire alone ou avec les critères de
notre actualité alors franchement si
vous prenez henri iv que j'aime
tendrement que vous avez si vous prenez
louis xiv
si vous prenez napoléon oui il y aurait
eu avec les critères d'aujourd'hui il y
aurait bien des choses à leur reprocher
bien des scandales qui pourrait faire
les femmes tabloïds et probablement des
protestations fondée sur la manière dont
il voyait les femmes
ouais est ce que pour autant ce sont des
gens qu'il faut écarter effacé de la
route c'est stupide important ya pas de
rue napoléon a pour nom n'aura pas je
vais prier je ne faisais pas réfléchi à
sa délibération du prochain conseil mais
c'est pas le chien seul et il n'y en a
quasiment pas en france je vous promets
ali baddou que je vous consulterait sur
la dénomination des rues à pau avec
plaisir je serai au rendez vous je sais
pas si je serai de très bons conseils
mais en tout cas je serai là merci merci
françois bayrou bon dimanche merci
alexandre gilardi à toute l'équipe
technique de questions politiques et
merci de nous avoir suivis à dimanche
prochain
[Musique]